you know what's funny right now is uh
here in los angeles it's actually
chilly like you wake up in the morning
and uh
it's in trust me this is how it is in
l.a
it's maybe in the high 50s yeah and
everyone is wearing parkas
everyone's acting i grew up in boston so
i don't know what the big deal is
but we got to the theater uh today
and someone had turned the heater on in
this cookie theater
and it sounded like a thousand ice
machines
from the turn of the century like 1902
ice machines
were grinding and they started to say
let's shoot the show and i'm like we
can't shoot the show with that
turn it off and the irish guy
who runs the theater flanny who's
sitting here in front uh he was like we
can't be turning it
off we'll all freeze to death
we'll freeze i said we'll freeze and he
was like
it's it's 68 degrees outside
that's exactly how you talk isn't it
flanny raccoons raccoons
raccoons running around this theater
he's always chasing me around i'll get
those raccoons
ridiculous i can't believe we're filming
in this place but anyway
uh we've turned off the heat and um you
know i've just decided to wear this
slightly warmer shirt right you can do
your lumberjack cosplay that you love to
do
i love lumberjack cosplay i used to do a
lot of porn as the brawny paper towel
guy
i remember remember yeah yeah that was i
mean remember oh yeah i remember
oh boy do i remember that was good stuff